Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish. A complex for the
elderly caught fire during the
early hours of the morning.
in the morning near histrion and
washington firefighters believe the
fire started on the second floor
all residents of the building were
evacuated and thankfully no one
was injured
there will be another clark county board of directors meeting later
today which
promises to be just as  intense than
yesterday the board will now discuss the
contract of doctor jesús jara three
members raised concerns
from parents and the
school workforce other members also
want to remove the president at the
edge of cavazos kirk and williams from the
board of directors 17 alleges  that
cavazos bullied some members of the
board if this is verified just or
could  losing the chairperson job
another on-script demonstration
by culinary union workers expected
tonight workers ask their
employers to call them back
to work union says 35
percent of its members are still
unemployed this  translates to about
21,000 people still not going back
to work
and temperatures today
really nice we'll see
temperatures hitting 80 degrees
through
Halloween Sunday really spectacular for
when the kids go trick-or-treating
already  you won't need to be
warm however there will be some
clouds in the valley by saturday although
the temperatures will be in the 70s i am
cristian cásseres with your
informative award from news now in spanish
good day
[Music]